so I saw this on CNN yesterday well I
don't have a television with cable but I
saw a clip of it on the computer over
there that CNN is going after uh Ron
DeSantis of course and why are they
going after him well I think we just
laid out a good casework right he's
fighting against the woke he's fighting
for a digital Bill of Rights you know
all the reasons check out this
ridiculously slanted piece that they did
about Ron DeSantis and Clarence Thomas
and wonder why this Chris Licht is
stepping down today
also this morning new details about the
close relationship between Republican
presidential candidate Ron DeSantis and
Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas it
has to do with one connection really
Leonard Leo a conservative activist who
had previously advised both the Santos
and Donald Trump on judicial nominations
Leo is also friends with Justice Thomas
so three years ago at an event for the
Florida chapter of the Federalist
Society DeSantis said this about Justice
Thomas
this is a Justice that has the courage
of his convictions and he's willing to
apply the Constitution you know
regardless of any criticism that he may
face because I do think he is our
greatest living Justice thank you
[Applause]
and after that speech DeSantis Thomas
and Leo all went out to dinner guys
Ron DeSantis eats dinner
with a black guy
who happens to be a pretty cool black
guy do you realize how insane this is
the the hypocrisy of these people is so
ridiculous they thought they just had
some sort of bombshell that robbed
DeSantis the governor of Florida trying
to become the president of the United
States went to an event said nice things
about Clarence Thomas who's a Supreme
Court Justice they happen to agree you
know basically on the issues on how the
Constitution uh should be treated and
how you know we should live by the laws
of the land and that sort of thing they
take video the video is public it's not
like he privately said something about
Clarence Thomas and then it was leaked
it was like but they make of this
nonsense and then the NPCs the
non-playable characters who watch CNN
they then have dinner with people and
they go my god did you see that
bombshell report on CNN do you know that
Ron DeSantis with some other guy had
dinner with Clarence Thomas and then
somebody goes my God I better tell
somebody about that it's so absolutely
insane but they cannot stop themselves
[Music]
foreign